la capitale des et figure d'exception en
france jusqu'à présent paris était la
seule grande ville à ne pas disposer de
police municipale une particularité
alors que depuis les années 70 de plus
en plus de communes se dote de policiers
municipaux comme ici à marseille en 1974
veillez au respect des règles de
circulation et de stationnement dans les
rues de marseille
assurer la sécurité des piétons
notamment aux entrées et aux sorties les
écoles telles seront donc les missions
confiées aux futurs policiers municipaux
une police municipale à marseille mais
aussi à rennes ou à nice en revanche
paris reste encore à l'écart en 1985
malgré la montée de l'insécurité jacques
chirac maire de la capitale refuse la
création d'une police municipale seront
ouverts de police ou un loyer la voir
monsieur le maire je n'ai pas dit cela
c'est un autre problème
je crois effectivement qu'il est naturel
et légitime que ce soit l'état qui est
la police je ne conteste donc pas cette
orientation
jacques chirac y est opposée son
successeur jean tiberi aussi tous les
deux craignent des tensions avec la
police nationale
mais le débat est lancé en 1986 c'est
élus parisiens militer pour une police
municipale à paris il s'agit d'abord de
prévention bien sûr mais donnée au maire
de paris
les mêmes pouvoirs comme maire de
marseille au maire de lille jacques
chirac s'y opposent
avant de changer d'avis en 1990 bien
qu'ayant toujours été contre le principe
des polices municipales
je serai amené à revoir complètement la
gestion de paris à diminuer de façon
drastique un certain nombre de dépenses
dans la capitale et d'affecter cet
argent à la création d'une police
municipale
malgré son avis favorable toujours pas
de police municipale à paris en 1998
jean pierre chevènement alors ministre
de l'intérieur
créer une police de proximité en france
à paris elle se déploie un an plus tard
mais dépend de la police nationale
but étant une présence accrue est
visible sur la voie publique
le recueil des plaintes puis les
enquêtes de police judiciaire et bien
sûr la police des quartiers l'îlotage
ayant déjà fait ses preuves
cette police de proximité supprimée en
2003 par nicolas sarkozy alors ministre
de l'intérieur
les années passent et paris n'a toujours
pas sa police municipale en 2013
le débat est relancé à l'occasion des
élections municipales la droite y est
favorable
la gauche opposée moi je ne propose pas
par exemple de police municipale je veux
qu'on continue une coopération avec la
préfecture de police de paris
finalement après avoir remporté la
mairie de paris anne hidalgo change
d'avis elle plaide pour la création
d'une police municipale en 2017
suite au feu vert de l'assemblée
nationale des premiers agents pour être
déployés sur le terrain dès 2021
[Musique]